some of these dudes by becoming King by
being having a better Army at the right
time you know William the Conqueror
whatever has is in the right place at
the right time with the right Army you
know and there's a weakness at the right
moment and he comes over and he exploits
it and ends up probably having you know
I don't know a thousand children and
those children are high up people who
might be have a ton
the species is different now because of
him like if that if they forget
England's different or you know European
borders look different like like we are
like we look different and because of a
small handful of of people
um you know yeah certain when I
sometimes I think I'm like oh you know
this part of the world I can recognize
someone's Greek you know someone's
Persian someone's wherever because you
know they kind of have certain facial
features and I'm like it may have
happened I mean obviously it's that's a
population but it may be that like
someone 600 years ago that looked like
that really spread their seed and that's
why the ethnicity looks kind of like
that now sorry anyway
yeah yeah do you think individuals like
that can turn the direction of History
or is that an illusion that narrative
would tell ourselves
well it's both I mean so I said William
the Conqueror right or Hitler right
it's not that Hitler was born and
destined to be great at all right I
think in a lot of cases he's um
frustrated artist with a temper who's
turning over the table in his studio and
hitting his wife and being kind of a
dick uh and a total nobody right
um I think almost all the times you
could have put Hitler baby on Earth he's
uh he's a rando right you know and maybe
he's a you know maybe sometimes he
becomes a you know some kind of you know
he uses the speaking ability because
that ability was going to be there
either way but maybe he uses it for
something else
but
um but that said I don't also do I think
you but it's not that um oh World War II
was gonna happen either way right so
it's both it's that like these
circumstances were one way and this
person
came along at the right time and those
two made a match made in in this case
hell but it makes you wonder
yes it's a match in hell but are there
other people that could have taken this
place or do these people that stand out
they're the rare spark of uh
that genius whether it take us towards
evil towards good whether those figures
singularly Define the trajectory of
humanity you know what defines the
trajectory of humanity in the 21st
century for example might be the
influence of AI might be the influence
of nuclear war negative or positive
not in the case of nuclear war but uh
the bioengineering
nanotech
virology
what else is there maybe the structure
of governments and so on maybe the
structure of universities I don't know
there could be singular figures that
stand up and lead the way for human
there will be but I wonder if the
society is the thing that manifests that
that person or that person really does
have a huge impact I think it's probably
a spectrum where there are some cases
when a circumstance was such that
something like what happened was gonna
happen if you pluck that person from the
earth I don't know whether the Mongols
is a good example or not but maybe it
could be that if you plucked Genghis
Khan as a baby
there was because of the specific way
Chinese civilization was at that time
and the specific
you know climate you know that was that
was causing a certain kind of pressure
on the Mongols and the way they they
still had their the great archers and
they had their horses and they had a lot
of the same advantages so maybe it was
like it was waiting to happen right it
was going to happen either way and uh
may not have happened to sit to the
extent or whatever so maybe or you could
go the full other direction and say
actually this was probably not going to
happen
um and you know I think World War II is
an example where I kind of think World
War II really was kind of the the work
of it of course it relied on all these
other circumstances you had to have the
resentment in German you have to have
the Great Depression but like
um I think if you take Hitler out I'm
pretty sure World War One World War II
doesn't happen